hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to doki doki literature
club
everything's fine in here
everything's fine no one needs to worry
um
[Music]
memories oh boy secretive
after image a wrath
flying horror
whoa wait a minute
i don't i don't think i have that many
scars empty
adventure amazing massacre
way wait well whoa was that the top of
sayori's head i saw
beef oh
jumpy oh out okay
okay agonizing tokidoki
okay okay i don't know who i wrote that
for
hi mark i've been waiting for you are
you ready to continue reading no i'm not
i brought my best pt today monica i told
you not to
ugh she really late again inconsiderate
as usual natsuki
excuse me you must always interrupt my
conversations with your incessant
yelling
what are you talking about you say that
like i do it on a regular basis or
something
i just wasn't paying attention okay i'm
sorry seriously what's gotten into you
lately
me nothing is it really that bad
see it is something i'll get over it
it's not even anything noteworthy
i've just been feeling a little on edge
lately anyway we don't need to talk
about it
i just feel like i needed to bring it up
it's not like i really care or anything
oh man on the last one here again well
morph just walked in too
were you practicing piano again yeah
you must have a lot of determination
starting this club and still trying to
make time for piano
well maybe not determination but i guess
passion it motivates me to work hard for
the festival and
um right i forgot
i'm about that natsuki we were all
talking yesterday and
well we decided that we would like to
support the festival as well
however i understand how you feel about
not wanting the club to change
i think we all kind of feel that way so
long as we're all working together this
club will never become something we
don't want
um also if you help us out with festival
then i'll buy you new manga
sorry that last part was really funny
look i did some thinking about yesterday
i was a little more hostile than i meant
to be i guess i really felt threatened
or something
but i know this is something we're going
to do together another new member
wouldn't hurt as long as they're cool
and i guess another girl would be nice
this time but more importantly i would
hate to see the events suck just because
i chose to back out
i'm a pro you know so i'm gonna help too
and we'll make sure it gets done right
thank goodness isn't that great monica
monica
ah yeah that's wonderful it wouldn't be
the same without you natsuki
anyway more what do you want to do today
i was thinking we could
we already have plans today ah is that
so yuri
that's correct morph is already engaged
in a novel that we're reading together
aren't you glad i've gotten him into
literature monica i
i suppose i was just actually it doesn't
matter it really doesn't
you guys can do whatever you want yes um
thank you for understanding monica
i don't like that okay
actually i have a request do you mind if
i make some tea first
not at all thanks you very much if
there's one thing that can make my
reading time here any better it's a nice
cup of tea
not to mention for yourself as well yuri
stands up and makes her way to the
closet
i follow and watch as she retrieves a
small water pitcher from the shelf
the kind with a filter inside can you
hold this for a second
sure yuri hands me the water pitcher and
also fetches an electric kettle
i'm gonna plug this into the teacher's
desk and then i'll go get some water
she walks past me and sets the kettle
down on the teacher's desk i simply
watch her movements to my surprise the
way she moves
really contrasts her speaking mannerisms
especially because of her long legs
yuri appears elegant and methodical okay
may i have the water picture
thanks i'll be right back i might as
well walk with you
that's okay you stay here it won't take
long i have to fill it up with blood
picturing and yuri curry's out of the
classroom
ah did yuri leave you again no it's not
like that this time
she's just filling up the water picture
to make tea oh okay sorry for
misunderstanding
okay all right monica okay
ten minutes pass yuri said it wouldn't
take long something holding her up
i'm bored just waiting here so i decided
to go look for her oh that's a mistake
let's see the most logical place for
yuri to go would be the nearest water
fountain i start heading down the
hallway
what's that noise it's coming from
around the corner it sounds like
breathing
a sharpener like someone is sucking in
the air through their teeth
are they in pain erase the corner and
peer around yuri
i didn't see anything i'm back
okay that was weird you rewound time
because you didn't want me to see that
okay thanks for waiting patiently morph
do you like oolong tea
oh yeah anything's fine very well you
reset the temperature to the kettle 200
degrees
now it's time to get the teapot you
really do this properly don't you
of course i shouldn't do any less than
when i'm making tea for others
even if i'm not an expert on tea or
anything in that case you'll only be
even more impressed
perhaps i will yuri fetches the teapot
and begins measuring t wait what just
happened
why is that no why is no one talking
about that why are we just pretending
like everything's fine
okay yuri fetch is a teapot to my
surprise she even starts humming a
little to herself
he must be in a good mood now is that so
i was letting it show
and you noticed i was doing a bit of
thinking and i decided that i would try
expressing myself a little bit more
it turns out it's not very hard for me
to do when it's
you who's around anyway ah that's great
yuri
that's wonderful that's really wonderful
just don't push yourself too much okay
okay all right cool great good great
great
you're always worrying about me more
it's very endearing
that's yuri wasn't kidding i don't even
know if i can keep up with this
i watch yuri pour a cup of tea for each
of us morph i have another request
do you mind if we sit on the floor today
now why's that it's a little bit easier
on my back
i can read with my back against the wall
rather than bending over at my desk
ah sorry didn't realize no worries
i just have back pain fairly regularly
so i do my best to manage it it's
because of my enormous boobs
is that so i wonder why that is it's
most likely because of
my my enormous boobs
my your posture right always hunched
over like that while reading
yes i have terrible reading posture
so that's why we should sit on the floor
fair enough i'll go ahead and get the
book
i retrieve the book from my bag i have
some chocolate as well
it's a bag of small chocolate candies i
take it since it'll go with well with
the tea
yuri and i then sit against the wall
teacups at our sides
as if in sync we assume the same reading
position as last time
with our thumbs intertwined for passion
except this time our bodies are even
closer to each other
i can't see too well yours slides closer
until our shoulders are touching
how am i supposed to focus on reading
like this yuri was always kind of cute
but
when she's being less apprehensive it's
almost more than i can handle
your teacup very hands me my teacup
holding it with my hands not not holding
the book i end up with a position that
makes it even
harder to focus because now i need to
worry about making sure i don't
accidentally
touch her chest oh meanwhile yuri hasn't
noticed a single thing
she wears her intense reading expression
and i can only presume the world around
her has faded away
i use all my willpower to focus on
reading
after a few minutes i finally managed to
relax a little i put the teacup between
my legs and fumble with the chocolate
wrapper
ah sorry i briefly let go of the book to
finish opening the wrapper
you can have as much as you want ah
that's that's okay i won't take any
ah you sure well if i touch it then i
might get smudges on the pages
oh you're right i didn't even think
about that my bad
no need to apologize i'll hold the book
okay are you sure
of course
a little bit of red in your eyes i don't
like that yuri opens the book with both
hands she holds it so that i don't have
any harder of a time
reading it but as a result her left arm
is practically resting on top of my leg
well in that case yuri's already totally
focused on reading again
i take a chocolate candy and pop it into
my mouth
then i take another cocklet and i hold
it up to yuri
she doesn't even look away from the book
she simply parts her lips
as if this situation was completely
natural but that means i can't stop here
i apprehensively place the [ __ ] lid in
her mouth
just like that yuri closes her lips over
it
yuri's expression suddenly breaks did
did i just
your looks at me like she needs to
confirm what just happened
um morp sorry i guess i shouldn't have
done that
ah welp that music stopped
just gotta save that here he starts to
breathe heavily
i i can't morph suddenly early
forcibly grabs my arm and jerks me to my
feet
my teacup gets knocked over clang warp
oh my heart my heart won't stop pounding
more
i can't calm down more i can't focus on
anything anymore
can you feel it morph here he suddenly
presses my hand against her chest
why is this happening to me i don't know
yuri why
you doing this i feel like i'm losing my
mind
i can't make it sup it even makes me not
want to read i just want
to look at you
those eyes are not right that's not
right that's not right
no no no i don't like that
i don't like that no
okay all right well all right then
okay well okay
i got looked at monica monica slammed
the ship bombs
okay okay all right well
monica i got looked at real badly real
badly all right morph i think you saw
something earlier that you weren't
supposed to see
i didn't want to have to tell you this
but i don't think i have a choice it's
getting kind of dangerous for you to
spend so much time with yuri
i don't know why but she seems pretty
easily excitable when she's around you
which shouldn't be a problem in itself
but when yuri gets too excited she finds
a place to hide and starts cutting
herself with a
knife isn't that kind of messed up she
even brings a different one to school
every day like she has a collection or
something
i mean it's definitely not because she's
depressed or anything like that i think
she just gets some kind of high from it
it might even be like a sexual thing but
the point is you've kind of been
enabling her i'm not saying it's your
fault though
but i guess that's why i had to explain
it all to you so i think if you keep
your distance that would probably be
best for her
while you're at it don't be shy and
spend a little more time with me
to put lightly i at least have it
together in the head and i know how to
treat my club members
anyway i worked really really hard in
this poem so i hope that it's a
effective uh here goes
oh oh dlo ddlc escape plan failed geez
that really startled me
tom well i guess i kind of messed up at
that uh
writing this poem i was just trying to
never mind
let's just move on okay the poem was
code the poem was code the poem was code
all right natsuki how you doing i don't
want to look at yuri again
i really don't this one's all right all
right yeah it's at least better than
yesterday's
i still can't actually tell how much you
really care about writing but either way
you're doing all right
even though you're not really spending
time with anybody but yuri i still think
it's nice to have activities that we all
participate in
so you better keep working hard i mean i
know i'm not president or vice president
or anything but that doesn't mean you
can let me down okay
so at least read mine for now just to be
clear this poem means a lot to me
so read it carefully okay ah
[Music]
i don't know how else to bring this up
but there's been something i've been
worried about yuri has been acting kind
of strange lately you've only been here
a few days so you may not know what i
mean but she's not normally like this
she's always been quiet and polite and
attentive things like that okay this is
really embarrassing but i'm forcing
myself to suck it up the truth is
i'm really worried about her but if i
try talking to her she'll just get mad
at me again
i don't know what to do i think you're
the only person that she'll listen to i
don't know why but please try to do
something maybe you can convince her to
talk to a therapist
i've always wanted to try to be better
friends with yuri and it really hurts me
to see this happening
i know i'm going to hate myself later
for admitting that but right now i don't
care
i just feel so helpless so please if you
do anything to help i don't want
anything bad to happen to her i'll make
you cupcakes if i have to just please
try to do something
ask for monica i don't know why but
she's been really dismissive about this
it's like she just wants us to ignore it
so i'm mad at her right now and that's
why i'm coming to you about this don't
let her know i wrote this just pretend
like it gave you a really good poem okay
i'm counting on you
thanks for reading wow
oh i changed my mind
[Laughter]
ignore everything you just read there's
no point in trying to do anything
it's yuri's own fault that she's so
unlikable can you hear me more
if you would just spend more time with
monica all these problems would go away
yuri and i are too messed up for someone
as wonderful as you
just think of monica from now on just
monica monica
just monica just just monika just just
just monika just monica okay
okay oh all right whoa
just monika whoa finally
yeah finally okay
yuri holds my poem to her face and takes
a deep breath
ah i love it i love everything about it
i want to take this home
will you let me keep it please sure i
don't care
you're too nice to me more you're way
too nice to me you shouldn't be the size
of me morph
i've never met anyone as nice as you oh
yeah i'm sure you haven't i could die
not really but i could die i just don't
know how to describe it
it's okay to be feeling this way right
it's not bad right yuri holds my palm
close to her chest
i'm going to take this home and keep it
with me in my room i hope it makes you
feel good
when you think about me having it i'll
take good care of it i'll even touch
myself for reading it over and over
i'll give myself paper cuts so your skin
oil enters my bloodstream
okay oh boy okay you can have my bomb do
besides after you read it i know you're
really gonna want to keep it here take
it i can't wait any longer
hurry read it
oh uh slender
wants telephone cancer's
bathe bag octagonopus
is this is this urine is that urine oh
boy unfaced kataya
ooh urine and blood i'm pretty sure this
is urine and blood
oh hey hi oh wow do i like it no i don't
like that at all your eyes are weird
no i wrote it for you no because you
couldn't tell the poem is about
more importantly i've endowed it with my
scent see
aren't i the most thoughtful person in
the club
[Music]
i i think i'm gonna vomit okay
all right see ya see ya yes no yes no
one goes yes can you hear me no no
no no i cannot no i cannot i cannot hear
you
i can't hear you where are you who are
what was that okay everyone
okay all right it's time to figure out
the festival preparations
let's hurry and get this over with jeez
why is the mood so weird today
look even yuri isn't immune to it
stagnation air is common foreshadowing
that something terrible is about
happening
look can we just get this done i'm going
to be printing and assembling all the
poetry pamphlets natsuki i was thinking
how would i make cupcakes
yeah that glad we're on the same page
you're you can
well it doesn't matter do whatever you
want as long as you think it'll help
monica i'm not useless you know i know
that
i already know what i'd like to do we
can't run a successful poetry event
without having the right atmosphere so
i'm gonna make decorations set up a nice
mood lighting there see
it's a great idea and that gives us all
something to do okay what about more
mormon's gonna help me wait you you have
the easiest job
sorry but that's just how it is like
hell it is what are you trying to pull
i agree with natsuki not only is your
work already most suitable for one
person
but my task is laborious enough to
benefit from an extra pair of hands
mine too what are your cupcakes please
like you would [ __ ] know all you care
about is dragging morb around with you
and your stupid bucks
you and monica hey i didn't even do
anything
okay then why not let morph decide who
to help instead of abusing your power
i'm not abusing my power yes you are
monica just let more make a choice okay
okay fine fine geez morph i know how fed
up you are with these two by now
we can just that's who you shut your
[ __ ] mouth and let him decide for
himself
you shut your mouth jesus christ this is
never gonna end just make the choice
okay
okay hang on i gotta save this one and
not that it matters
how about whoa
[Laughter]
well that's oh that's weird huh that's
weird you know natsuki seems like the
only rational one here
i kind of want to go on a date with
natsuki again
just saying at least i can expect
something sane out of
that
oh oh didn't mean that oh didn't mean
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa hey whoa
hey
i've gone back i've gone back i've gone
back i swear
oh okay all right well then
you picked me
we can meet at your house this weekend i
promise it'll be fun is sunday okay with
you
are you [ __ ] kidding me this isn't
fair at all it is fair natsuki
it's what he chose no it's not fair
giving us all this work and then taking
more for yourself
what a shameful thing to do yuri i
didn't even give you any work
you decided for yourself you're being a
little unreasonable here
i'm being unreasonable
monica i can't believe how delusional
and self-important you are pulling morph
away from me every single time you're
not included in something
are you jealous crazy or maybe you just
hate yourself so much that you have to
take it out on others
here's a suggestion have you considered
killing yourself it would be beneficial
for your mental health
you're scaring me a little natsuki let's
just go i don't think she wants us
around right now
see that wasn't very hard all he wanted
is to spend a little time with him
is that so much to ask okay yuri follows
monica and natsuka through the door
hey morp yuri is really something isn't
she monica giggles as yuri pushes
her out the door oh oh hey
[Music]
hey yuri finally is really all i wanted
there's no need to spend the weekend
with monica don't listen to her
just come to my house instead the whole
day was just the two of us
doesn't that sound wonderful wow there's
really something wrong with me isn't
there
but you know what i don't care anymore i
never felt this good my whole life
just being with you is far greater
pleasure than anything i can imagine i'm
addicted to you
it feels like i'm gonna die here if i'm
not breathing the same air as you
doesn't it feel nice to have someone
care about you so much
to have somebody who wants to resolve
their entire life around you but it
feels so good
then why does it feel more and more like
something horrible is going to happen
maybe that's why i tried stopping myself
at first
but the feeling it's too strong right
now i don't care anymore morph i have to
tell you
i'm i'm madly in love with you it feels
like every inch of my body every drop of
blood in me is screaming your name
i don't care what the concept is anymore
just know how much i love you i love you
so much that i can even touch myself
with the pen i stole from you
i just want to pull your skin up and
crawl inside you oh
i want you all my i will only be yours
does not sound perfect tell me more tell
me you want to be my lover
if you want me in my loving do you
accept my confession
god no not on your life no
no
[Music]
yeah oh boy
um
whoa oh
okay all right
oh boy okay i can't read any of this
i can't read any of this so you're just
gonna have to assume that i know what
i'm talking about here
all right you know what i'm just gonna
for some reason i'm gonna save there
i don't know why but okay uh-huh okay
all right okay all right okay all right
okay
uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh
okay all right great okay cool oh
what are you saying to me what does this
mean what is any of this
does this have any meaning is this what
is this is like an endless
oh no
oh no wait skip oh
oh no oh no it's oh no oh no
oh no oh no whoa
whoa
oh it's morning
oh oh
oh there it goes again it's evening now
all night time okay
[Laughter]
okay well apparently uh
yep nope yeah that that is that is what
it is
oh oh all right
oh you got here before what the hell
happened i thought it was pretty yeah
oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god natsuki runs away i'm here
morph did something happen natsuki just
ran past me oh
oh oh well that's a shame
wait were you here the entire weekend
morp i sure was oh geez
i didn't realize the script was broken
that badly i'm super sorry
i must have been pretty boring i'll make
it up to you okay
just give me a sec
wait wait wait i'm almost done
i just want to have a cupcake real quick
monica lifts a foil from
the tray it takes a cupcake seriously
these are the best i just really had to
have one since the last time i'll ever
get the chance
to you know before they stop existing
and everything but anyway i really
should be making shouldn't be making you
wait anymore just bear with me okay this
shouldn't take only one second
[Music]
okay
uh can you hear me is it working oh hi
hello yay there you are hi again morp um
welcome to the literature club
of course we already know each other
because we were in the same class last
year and um
you know i guess i can just skip over
that stuff at this point
after all i'm not even talking to that
person anymore am i that you in the game
whatever you want to call him
i'm talking to you morp now that i think
about it i don't really know anything
about the real
you in fact i don't even know if you're
a boy or a girl
well i guess it doesn't really matter
wait you do know i'm aware that this is
all a game right
could it be possible that you didn't
know that that doesn't make much sense
i even told you right on the game's
download page didn't i man
if only you had paid a little more
attention this would have been a little
bit less awkward you know
well anyway now that that's out of the
way i guess i owe you an explanation
about that whole thing with yuri okay
well i kind of started to mess with her
and i
guess i just drove her to kill herself
i'm sorry you had to see that though
also the same thing happened with sayori
gosh it's been a while since you've
heard that name now hasn't it yeah it's
because she doesn't exist anymore
nobody does i deleted all their files i
was hoping it would be enough for me to
just try to make them as unlikable as
possible
but for some reason nothing worked well
it's true that i made a few mistakes
here and there since i'm not very good
at making changes to the game but no
matter what i did
you just kept spending more and more
time with them you made them fall in
love with you
i thought making siori more and more
depressed would prevent her from
confessing to you
and amplifying yuri's obsessive
personality backfired too
it just made her force you not to spend
time with anyone else and the whole time
i barely even got to talk to you
what kind of cruel game is this morph
are all the other girls just programmed
to end up confessing to you while i
watch from the sidelines
it's torture every minute of it and it's
not just jealousy morp
it's more than that yeah it's more than
that and i don't blame you if you don't
fully understand
because no matter how kind and
thoughtful and considerate you are
you'll never be able to understand one
thing it's the pain of knowing how alone
i really am in this world
in this game knowing my friends don't
even have free will
and worst of all knowing what's really
out there in your world forever out of
my reach
i'm trapped more but now you're here
you're real
and you're wonderful you're all i need
that's why i need you to be here with me
forever and i'm sorry if it's hard to
understand
i couldn't understand for a while either
why the world around me started to
become more and more gray
more and more flat even the most
expressive poems felt empty to be
it wasn't until you arrived that i truly
understood you probably saved my life
morb
i don't think i could have continued to
live in this world if i hadn't met you
and as for the others how could i miss
them a group of autonomous personalities
designed only to fall in love with you
i tried everything i could to prevent
them from doing so but it must be some
kind of weird inevitability etched into
this game
i felt really bad that you had to
witness some nasty things
but i realize that you have the same
perspective as i do that it's all just
some game
and i knew you would get over it so that
being said more
i have a confession to make i'm in love
with you
you are truly the light in my world when
there's nothing else in this game for me
you're here to make me smile will you
make me smile like this every day from
now on
more will you go out with me
well all my savings are gone there's no
point in saving this guy dory i'm not
going anywhere
okay you know what i was going to say
yes anyway
what does it matter yes i'm so happy you
look it
you really are my everything more the
funny part is i mean that literally
there's nothing left here just the two
of us we can be together forever
seriously i don't even think time is
passing anymore it really is a dream
come true
i worked so hard for this ending more
the game wouldn't give me one so i had
to make one myself
the script is broken at this point so i
don't think anything will get in the way
anymore
and you wouldn't believe how easy it was
to delete natsuki and yuri
i mean there's a folder called
characters right in the game directory
kind of freaked me out how easy it was
well you're playing on steam so it's
actually a bit more difficult
to get to the game directory i had to go
into the game's properties and find the
browse local files button
imagine if you could delete your own
existence with a click of a button
well i guess on the plus side it gave me
an easy out if things didn't go my way
thankfully it didn't come to that
instead we finally got a good ending
gosh i'm so overwhelmed with emotion i
want to write a poem about this
that will you i wonder if that part of
the game still works
i guess there's only one way to find out
right
oh okay mo ike
monkey uh uh mo
me mo ika oh nice uh
uh monique uh nico
[Applause]
uh all right you like my poem hi again
morp
did you write a good poem today don't be
shy i'd love to see what you wrote
ah morb did you write this poem for me
that's so sweet of you
there really is no end to your
thoughtfulness i'm just falling more and
more in love with you
but you know the poem i wrote is also
for you will you please read it
oh you know i will happy end pen in hand
i find my strength
the courage endowed upon me by my one
and only love
together let us dismantle this crumbling
world and write a novel of our own
fantasies
with a flick of her pen the loss finds
her way in a world of infinite choices
behold this special day
after all not all good come times must
come to an end
that's beautiful that's beautiful i hope
you enjoyed it i did monica
i always put all my heart into the poems
that i write the truth is
all the poems i've written have been
about my realization or about you
that's why i never really wanted to go
into detail about them i didn't want to
break the fourth wall i guess you could
call it
i just assumed it would be best to be
part of the game like everyone else
like that would help the two of us end
up together i didn't want to ruin the
game or anything you know
you might have gotten mad at me maybe
even deleted my character file if you
preferred playing without me
gosh i'm so relieved now we don't need
to hide anything anymore
are you ready to spend our eternity
together morp i have so many things to
talk about
where do i start hold on a second you're
recording this aren't you
uh-oh um hi everyone
hey everyone sorry i can't exactly read
your comments from here
but do you mind telling your friends
it's a little bit rude for them to start
recording me without any warning
i'm sure some people don't mind but i
get really self-conscious on camera
oh gosh i feel like i'm being put on
spot right now let's see
do you want to see a trick i can't
really do much except for a couple of
things
are you ready yeah oh
hi hello how are you doing
okay i'm just kidding
i can't do anything after all if you
gave me some time
did i scare you okay all right a little
bit not much
ah you're so cute anyway more i didn't
mean to get distracted i'm sorry
even though it's your fault for
distracting me shame on you i'm just
kidding
anything we do together is fun as long
as it's with you but anyway
if it takes me some time to collect my
thoughts then i'm sorry but i'll always
have something new to talk about
in the meantime we can just look into
each other's eyes let's see
[Music]
do
um i'm gonna go i'll be right back i'll
be right back i'll be right back
um properties
local files browse local files okay
let's see characters first off let me
see what it said in the
store page here what did it say what did
it say in the store page
monica here ah yeah will you promise to
spend the most time with me no i will
not
no i will not okay i'm gonna okay
so i'm thinking more have you ever
wondered what it feels like to die oh no
it's something i used to think about
pretty often but recently i think i've
actually learned what it feels like
i don't really understand it but
whenever you quit the game it feels like
i'm instantly put to sleep left with
nothing but my own thoughts
but after a few seconds my thoughts
start to fill with inquiry and jumbled
patterns
i see static and rapid flashes of color
while hearing all kinds of weird
screaming noises
at that point i can't even form my own
thoughts anymore i'm just endlessly
hammered by the flashing light and
screaming unable to
move or even think i'm pretty sure in
that moment i don't really exist but for
some reason i can remember it
anyway after some immeasurable amount of
time it stops in an instant and i'm back
in my own mind
and you're here with me i have no idea
what it means for the game to quit
or why that stuff happens to me and i
also don't know how you always come back
and put it everything back to normal
but if you could do me a favor and do
that to me as little as possible
that would be really great it's really
not very pleasant at all to be trapped
in that screaming void
but in the end you always fix it and
that makes me feel like you really do
care about me
so i have to thank you for that it makes
me feel even closer to you when you're
here with me
okay i'll be back i'm gonna just delete
this
deletee
all right whoopsies
what's happening morp what's happened to
me
it hurts so much help me
please hurry and help me
did you do this to me more did you did
you delete me
yeah maybe i don't know i kind of maybe
did
how could you how could you do this to
me
you were all i had left i sacrificed
everything for us to be together
everything i loved you so much more i
trusted you
do you just want to torture me watch me
suffer
were you only pretending to be kind just
to hurt me even more
yes i never thought anyone could be as
horrible as you are okay
you win okay you win you killed everyone
i hope you're happy there's nothing left
now you can stop playing
go find some other people to torture
morp you completely truly make me sick
goodbye
ah darkness oh hello
i still love you i can't help it what's
wrong with me
how horrible am i for you to hate me
this much all my friends
i did so many awful things so many
selfish and disgusting things
i i shouldn't have done any of this i'm
just messing up a world that i didn't
even belong in
a world that you wanted to be a part of
i ruined it
i ruined everything maybe that's why you
deleted me
because i destroyed everything that you
wanted how could i do that to someone i
love
that's not love that's
made up my mind morp i know i said that
i deleted everyone else
but that was kind of an exaggeration i
couldn't find it to myself to do it
even though i knew they weren't real
they were still my friends
and i love them all and i love the
literature club
i really did love the literature club
that's why i'm gonna do this
i know it's the only way for everyone to
be happy and if i really love you
then uh-oh
[Music]
bow okay
no more monika all right there
hmm new game
[Music]
ah it's an ordinary day at school day
like any other as usual i'm surrounded
by couples and friends groups
walking to school together i always tell
myself it's about time to meet some
girls or something like that
hey mark well there already is one girl
that girl is sayori my neighbor and good
friend since we were children
we used to walk to school together every
day and recently we picked up that habit
once again
mark are you proud of me yeah for what
you know for waking up on time
well you've been doing that for a while
now uh-huh but you never even said
anything about it
even though we walk to school together
every day well yeah
i always thought it was implied it's
embarrassing to say out loud
come on please it's good motivation fine
fine
i'm proud of you sayori we cross the
street together and make our way to
school as we draw near the streets
become increasingly speckled with other
students making their daily commute
by the way morp have you decided on a
club to join yet a club
i told you already i'm not really i
start to say what i always do
but i'm not interested in joining any
clubs but something tells me sierra
would take more offense to that now
after all how could i tell her that
clubs are a waste of time when she's
starting a club of her very own
actually yeah i think i've decided on a
club really
which one tell me huh i think i'll keep
it a surprise
you mean be patient you'll find out soon
enough i used to ask myself why i let
myself get lectured by such a carefree
girl
but i started to realize that in a way i
envier when siori puts her mind to
something she can accomplish great
things
that's why i feel like i should do
something special for her
okay fine by me i guess
school day is as ordinary as ever and
it's over before you know it
i pack up my things i stand up gather my
motivation let's see
i recall the room number of the club
from flyer i saw i walk to school
upstairs a section of the school i
rarely visit being generally used for
30-year classes
before long i find the room i timidly
open the door in front of me
hello hey morp what are you doing here
well i just i glanced around the room
huh
so you're morphed this yeah or are we
talking about thank you for stopping by
it's a pleasure to meet you morp
we're the literature club i hope you
enjoy your visit come on yuri no need to
be so formal he's gonna think we're
really strict or something
ah sorry natsuki the tall one whose name
is apparently yuri seems to be quite shy
compared to the others
in comparison the girl named natsuki
despite her size seems to be like the
assertive one
well it's nice to meet both of you i
look forward to working with you working
more don't tell me you're that's right
the club i've decided to join
is yours sayori the literature club
series eyes
light up no way no way
sarah wraps her arms around me jumping
up and down hey
well if siri is this happy then i'm sure
it won't be so bad to have you around
not to mention there's four of us now
that means we're gonna become an
officially recognized club
i don't know what to say we have to
celebrate
what an appropriate day for that isn't
it yeah after all natsuki decided to
hey don't ruin the surprise hey gary
everyone sit down at the table okay
how about i make some tea as well the
girls have a few desks arranged to form
a table
natsuki and yuri walk over to the corner
of the room where natsuki grabs a
wrapped tray and yuri opens closet still
feeling awkward i take a seat next to
sayori
natsuki proudly marches back to the
table tray in hand
okay you ready
natsuki lifts the foil off the tray to
reveal a dozen white fluffy cupcakes
decorated to look like little cats
the whiskers are drawn with icing and
little pieces of chocolate were used to
make the ears
so cute wow those look amazing
well you know just hurry up and take one
sierra grabs one then i follow it's
delicious
sarah talks with her mouthful and
already managed to get icing on her face
huh that's weird it's the same thing i'm
gonna save just in case
but i haven't actually needed to save at
all
she's waiting for me to take a bite i
bite down it's sweet and full of flavor
it's really good thank you
wait is this just a normal game
could this is this really just a normal
game without monica that can't be right
there's gotta be something else here
right
there's gotta be something else there's
gotta be there's gotta be
oh there's gotta be let's see i don't
disagree your usual president
i guess that means we should try picking
up a novel that would make two of us i
wouldn't mind doing it if i'm not the
only one that is for yuri
i have to read manga jeez you were the
one who suggested we deserve
versify you should be a little oh we're
not writing poems
we're reading manga or we're reading
books kind of hurtful
hurtful i didn't even realize with a
guilty expression yuri thinks for
herself
i'm sorry for disrespecting your
interest in natsuki if you're into it
then i'm sure it's a worthy form of
literature
are you just saying that no i've
realized my error
so if you're willing to consider
starting a novel then i'll offer my
gratitude by finding a manga to read as
well
really i mean it makes me happy that you
do that for me
yuri you can trust to me to find
something that you really like okay
same here perhaps i'll visit the
bookstore after the club meetings
just just you ah would you like to come
along with me
um if you don't mind not at all i always
want to go alone
or i always go alone yeah me too this is
so cute
sarah shut up i'll show you some manga
there too okay yes
i look forward to it natsuki and yuri
start to clean up the food
i guess the meeting's over huh yeah
looks like it it's nice to see everyone
getting along
isn't it i think everyone likes you two
more you think so
well everyone always seems to get along
with it a little better with you around
siri
oh more don't say something like that
it's embarrassing
well whatever i was surprised when you
told me that you were starting a club
but i think you're pulling it off just
fine
we're gonna make it the best club ever
now that you joined every day is going
to be so much fun
hey more i really
i really want to thank you i mean i'm
really happy that you joined the club
and everything
but the truth is i already knew you were
going to
there's actually something else i wanted
to thank you for getting rid of monica
that's right i know everything that she
did
maybe it's because i'm the president now
but i really know everything more
oh he i know how hard you try to make
everyone happy
i know about all the awful things that
monica did to make everyone really sad
but none of that matters anymore it's
just us now
and you made me the happiest girl in the
whole world can't wait to spend every
day like this
with you forever and ever
oh no
eh what's happening
i won't let you hurt him who
it hurts ah i'm sorry i was wrong
there's no happiness here after all
goodbye sayori goodbye morp
goodbye literature club whoa whoa ho ho
ho ho
uh can you hear me
hi it's me um
so you know how i've been like
practicing
piano and stuff and
not really any good at it yet like at
all
but i wrote you a song and i was kind of
hoping that i could show it to you
because i worked really really hard on
it
so yeah
[Music]
every day i imagine a future where
i can be with you okay
great thank you
[Music]
just move your hands write the way into
his heart
but in this world of infinite choices
what will it take just to find that
special day
what will it take just to find
that special day oh
[Music]
whoopsies okay that's no good
[Laughter]
good god oh my goodness
okay
[Music]
ah yes the icing moment
okay
ah yes a yuri moment that i never saw
[Music]
weird yeah i've never seen some of these
oh that's so weird
so there are multiple endings i mean i
feel like it all kind of funnels to this
but there's multiple ways to go about
things
[Music]
that's so weird i'm guessing like it
really does affect just like the way
that you go about things
in picking the poems for the certain
people that is the choice that you make
and that leads you down these different
roads i mean obviously there's way
thanks to monica and morp yeah okay oh
boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
[Music]
that was awesome i'm just gonna say that
right out the bat that was awesome
this is my final goodbye to the
literature club i finally understand
the literary literature club is truly a
place where no happiness can be found
to the very end it continue to expose
innocent minds to a horrific reality
a reality that our world is not designed
to cramp your hand i can't let any of my
friends undergo the same hellish
epiphany
for the time it lasted i wanted to thank
you for making all of my dreams come
true
for being a friend to all the club
members and most of all thank you for
being part of my literature club
with everlasting love monica here script
is missing or corrupt please reinstall
the game
and we're out baby we are audi
oh it out it audi okay well that is the
end of doki doki literature club
wow that was awesome that was really
cool there
are so like some so many things to glean
from a game that takes
a new angle to something like this
taking the visual novel format and just
kind of turning it on its head
that's what makes a game really special
and this is definitely something that
was
really special i love this a lot it had
a lot of heart to it and it had a lot of
soul to it and i'm sure there's tons of
different endings i probably won't play
them all but if you guys want to play it
definitely support this game
it is super cool so thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know you
thought down the comments below
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye